لقد اصابني الرعب عندما
رايت فيديوهات لمدرسه النور في شمال غزه
كيف تم
[موسيقى]
سحقها ابو ديفه والناس عام في المدارس وين
الامن وين الامان حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
هنالك
130 من موظفي الاونر وتم قتلهم منذ بدايه
[موسيقى]
الحرب وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين الاونر عمرها من عمر النكبه
تاسست لتقديم المساعده والحمايه والمناصره
مؤقتا للاجئين حتى عودتهم الى ديارهم دام
المؤقت لاكثر من سبعه
[موسيقى]
عقود في الثامن من ديسمبر كانون الاول
1949 وبعد نكبه عام 48 تم تاسيس الاونروا
بموجب القرار رقم 302 الصادر عن الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده بهدف تقديم في برامج
الاغاثه المباشره والتشغيل للاجئ فلسطين
وبدات الوكاله عملياتها في الاول من شهر
مايو ايار عام
1950 في البدايه كانت الانور تستجيب
لاحتياجات ما يقرب من 750 الف لاجئ
فلسطيني صارت تعطينا مار كل واحد كرت رز
يعطونا سكر
يعطونا سمنه بقوا يعطونا حليب بالكيله
صاروا يعطونا تموين اللي يكد يعني حاجه
بسيطه اما اليوم فحوالي 5 ملايين لاجئ
فلسطيني مسجلون في الاونروا يحق لهم
الحصول على
خدماتها في 58 مخيم من مخيمات اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين ومنتشر في مناطق عمليات
الانرو الخمسه وهي قطاع غزه والضفه
الغربيه وسوريا
والاردن ولبنان في قطاع غزه لا غن على
الاطلاق عن الاونور ولا يستطيع
الفلسطينيون هنا في غزه ان يعيشوا بدون
الاونر وعلى سبيل
[موسيقى]
المثال
ا